Speaker 1: You know, I as many of you are,
I'm watching very closely vaccination numbers,
covid, case numbers, deaths, et cetera. We're
trying to figure out are we headed towards hell
again in the fall? What is happening with the
Delta variant? What about the next variant?
What's happening in Europe, which seems to sort
of be a leading indicator for what we might expect
here in the United States and so on and so forth.
And then you just look at what's happening around
the country and you realize, hey, guys, they're
fighting against us there. So the anti vax right
wing has become a monster essentially of its own,
making so big that they may prevent the country
from being as great as they claim to want it to
be. They talk about make America great again.
They talk about America first. They
talk about all this stuff, and then they
don't want to get vaccinated, which is what
will help the economy and it will help prevent
death and it will help prevent hospitalization.
And I want to look at some video with you today
of Arkansas Republican Governor Governor
Asa Hutchinson. Now, I don't want to go
overboard in my praise of Republicans, but I
want to mention that in the last week or so,
many prominent Republican leaders have
started being much more positive about
covid vaccines. I think it's basically motivated
by economic concerns and the realization that it's
increasingly becoming a Republican virus because
Republicans want vaccinations at such a lower rate
than Democrats. Overwhelmingly, you are seeing red
counties, Republican counties have a higher per
capita case rate. OK, so Governor Asa Hutchinson
does an event with state vaccine official Dr.
Jennifer Delamar. And he says very basic, simple
things like the vaccine doesn't cause infertility,
which is one conspiracy that's been floating
around and he gets booed. Listen to this.
Speaker 2: So does this impact
fertility? Well, the answer is
no. And that's been the data. But they.
Speaker 1: What kind of person boos the news
that, hey, great news, the vaccine doesn't
impact fertility as far as we know right now,
based on all the evidence we've seen,
they've created a monster they can't control.
Hutchinson then defers to the state's vaccine
authority, and it just gets very ugly.
Speaker 2: Dr. Delaney, you
want to answer that? So at this,
Speaker 1: it's delay, not delay. I apologize.
Speaker 3: And time. There is no evidence that
the. Shantelle.
Speaker 1:
Can you imagine?
Speaker 2: All right,
so go ahead, Dr. Bill. So there is no.
Speaker 1: This is the same energy from from
witch burnings, right? I mean, it's that they will
not hear any alternative view to this is a witch.
These are lies about vaccines.
Speaker 3: Go ahead, Dr. Phil. So
there is no medical evidence at this time
that the kolache vaccines impact fertility.
Unidentified: There is a
great deal of. I hope that
Speaker 3: illness itself causes problems
with pregnancy and fetal demise, so I
Speaker 1: so understand that the
evidence isn't that the vaccine causes
fertility issues. The evidence is covid can cause
issues with pregnancy. How do you talk rationally
with these people? I mean, how reach across
the aisle. Who who are you reaching out to?
And this is something that we're getting more
and more information about. I think it's worth
repeating. Women's periods and the immune
system are connected as a woman is about to
ovulate. Her immune system ramps itself up to
prevent any infectious agent from interfering
with the start of a pregnancy with the
fertilization and implantation of the egg.
Once that egg is fertilized and then implants, the
immune system dampens to accept the pregnancy. The
uterus has immune cells. Those can be affected by
hormonal changes. The immune system and cortisol,
which is the stress hormone, those are related and
periods respond to cortisol levels. So the long
and short of it is there are anecdotal reports of
a late period in some women. After the second dose
of the vaccine, it's possible that the covid
vaccines could impact one or maybe two periods
following the second dose in terms of a delay, for
example, because the immune system of the woman
is hard at work developing immunity or because
of cortisol levels. As Dr. Daliah is stating,
there is no evidence of an impact on fertility.
There's no evidence of any long term effects.
And there is evidence that a bigger risk to
pregnancy than being vaccinated is getting covid
for a pregnant woman. But the crowd doesn't want
to hear it. So, again, for everybody saying we've
got to just relate to these people, we've got
to reach across the aisle, get them vaccinated,
I'm with you. But how do you do that? Where they
literally start chanting, they become I hate
to use a term that is a portmanteau created by
former producer Louis. They become reverent. Yeah,
I know it's not a word, but you can look that one
up on Urban Dictionary. How do you calm them down?
They're experiencing this outrageous state of
like a hyper arousal where they just can't stop
screaming when a doctor is simply saying there's
no evidence of that. I don't know how you connect
with those people, but it is very scary stuff
in terms of what it means for the United States
reaching herd immunity, if that's even still
something we think we might be able to do.